io sono sempre stato
affermazione che bisogna prendere il
primo 3
passa io credo che bisogna
impegnarsi molto per far sì che noi
possiamo creare le condizioni per farli
tornare questi treni in qualche modo fin
da quando siamo ragazzi ci hanno sempre
detto che ci dovevamo dovevamo fare
delle scelte giuste dovevamo
concentrarci perché sarebbe stato
impossibile tornare indietro nel caso in
cui avessimo preso una decisione
sbagliata la mia vita mi ha portato alla
conclusione che questa cosa
assolutamente sbagliata non solo quando
soprattutto quando siamo giovani
sbagliare non è così grave ma
addirittura è fondamentale secondo me
per costruire la nostra personalità per
la nostra persona quindi in pratica è
vero che ci sono delle decisioni che
possono essere determinanti eppure a
volte irreversibili e che in qualche
modo possono rallentare o deviare il
percorso naturale della nostra vita ma è
anche vero secondo me è che con
l'impegno con la passione con la
dedizione possiamo superare qualsiasi
tipo di ostacolo quindi dobbiamo
lavorare per fare questo la mia vita è
piena di esempi di questo tipo ce ne
sono due in particolare che vi vorrei
raccontare ci sono due episodi che sono
successi in tempi e modi separati
diversi tra loro ma che poi alla fine si
sono legati intrecciati per dare vita a
qualcosa se vogliamo di assolutamente
sorprendente circa 20 anni fa sono
andato con la mia compagna dell'epoca in
vacanza a new york
io non ci volevo neanche andare perché
era agosto le aveva le ferie solo
d'estate da buon calabrese volevo andare
al mare però alla fine ci sono andato e
devo dire devo dirle grazie di questa
cosa perché questa città mi ha
praticamente folgorato come tutti coloro
che arrivano per la prima volta a new
york lo so se vi è capitato di farlo mi
sentivo pervaso da questa energia
positiva
non riuscivo a stare un minuto fermo a
un certo punto ho cominciato a pensare
che quella fosse veramente la mia città
mi ricordo un episodio particolare
praticamente passando davanti al madison
square garden
c'è stata un illuminazione perché per me
da appassionato di musica e di sport il
madison square garden era un'istituzione
e quindi ho chiesto alla mia compagna
dell'epoca di riscattarmi una foto per
immortalare quel momento pensando chissà
quando ci torno al madison square garden
e chissà quando ci torno in questa città
è praticamente all'epoca non c'erano
nelle macchinette digitali né tantomeno
gli smartphone che permettevano di
controllare l'inquadratura e mi sono
fidato della mano della mia compagna non
c'era la possibilità di rivedere sul
momento una foto e quindi la foto andava
sviluppata quando sono tornato a
soverato e sono andato a guardare la
foto che mi sa che mi era stata fatta ed
era esattamente questa praticamente
passando da questa che sta scritto a
caratteri cubitali in madison square
garden la scritta non c'era più c'ero
solo io praticamente potevo essere
ovunque al comune di soverato piuttosto
che alla galleria di via san giovanni
bosco potevo essere quindi devo dire che
ci rimasi malissimo però prescindere da
questo da questo diciamo inconveniente
chiamiamolo così è veramente un risata
pensare che quella potesse essere la mia
città e ho iniziato a pensare che
potesse veramente andarci a vivere e
lavorare ma era molto difficile primo
perché non sapevo la lingua a scuola
avevo fatto francese e se non sai la
lingua difficilmente trovi un lavoro
qualcuno ti offre un lavoro anche perché
siccome new york è una città carissima
andarci e provare
restando sul posto
sarebbe significato per praticamente per
me fare la fame e poi soprattutto c'era
il discorso del visto perché nessuno ti
dà un visto di lavoro per andare a
lavorare negli stati uniti è molto più
facile vincere alla lotteria che non
prendere un visto di lavoro per gli
stati uniti però in qualche modo mi ero
messo in testa che devo fare questa cosa
quindi sono tornato qua e con un inglese
abbastanza elementare meno che
elementare forse ho cominciato piano
piano a mandare in giro il mio
curriculum
mi sono iscritto su un sito di lavori
specifici per il cinema e la televisione
del resto era un tecnico del suono
quindi potevo magari farcela in qualche
modo ho iniziato a parlare con degli
operatori del settore che si sono resi
molto disponibili a darmi dei consigli
dei suggerimenti anche se poi alla fine
gli americani sono molto friendly
soltanto di facciata è molto facile
conoscere delle persone ma allo stesso
tempo è molto difficile mantenere delle
relazioni però piano piano ci ho provato
questa cosa è durata diversi anni ormai
mi ero messo in testa che dovevo farcela
nel frattempo il mio inutile se
progrediva perché comunque ho dovuto
sostenere tre esami all'università il
mio corso di laurea prevedeva tre esami
in inglese quindi piano piano ho
iniziato a destreggiarmi però per molto
tempo nulla era praticamente impossibile
da qui a trovare un lavoro
dall'altra parte del mondo fin quando un
anno tornò a soverato in vacanza e sulla
spiaggia di soverato incontro un
imprenditore in vacanza che aveva
un'azienda di produzioni televisive a
new york che mi ha offerto di andare a
lavorare là e quindi ho detto vabbè ma
alla fine ho fatto tutto il giro del
mondo ce l'avevo trovata è incrociarlo
sotto casa e e sapete che cosa ho fatto
io ho rifiutato
ho rifiutato perché nonostante questa
possibilità che mi era stata data in
quel momento io sentivo in core mio che
non era la cosa giusta da fare
quindi mi sono reso disponibile a
collaborare con lui dall'italia da qui
da roma dove abitavo però non era
impensabile per me in quel momento
trasferirmi a new york per quale motivo
perché c'era la mia compagna quella del
madison square garden che è praticamente
si era appena trasferita a new york a
roma per venire a vivere con me aveva
lasciato il suo lavoro qui è un
contratto a tempo indeterminato e quindi
sera piano piano inserita a roma
onestamente mi prendeva malissimo
chiederle di trasferirsi di nuovo
dall'altra parte del mondo sia perché
lei non parlava inglese sia perché
comunque il suo lavoro prevedeva delle
modalità diverse rispetto a come si fa
negli stati uniti quindi avrebbe dovuto
accontentarsi della prima cosa che le
fosse successa capitata e quindi ho
detto di no
chiuso il discorso new york continuerò a
lavorare a roma
fin quando dopo qualche tempo vengo
assunto dalla rai al tg3
quindi un operatore della dell'industria
audiovisiva che viene assunto dalla
principale azienda televisiva del paese
dovrebbe fare i salti di gioia
e invece per me non era così e volevo
fare vedere la foto che mano scattato il
giorno in cui ho firmato il contratto
questa io questa foto la tengo sempre
come con me perché alla fine mi sono mi
sono convinto che ogni volta che che che
prendo un lavoro nuovo non devo avere
quella faccia se o quella faccia vuol
dire che il lavoro non va bene e quindi
sentivo praticamente che non era non era
quello che volevo fare praticamente era
un ambiente in cui non mi trovavo era
una posizione non adatta a me
addirittura a un certo punto avevo
sentito parlare due persone che erano
anche più giovani di me ma siano messi a
parlare di quando sarebbero andati in
pensione quindi cominciavano a farsi i
calcoli per la pensione io onestamente
in un ambiente così non ci volevo stare
allora che è successo ho chiaramente
accettato quel lavoro firmato il
contratto ma dopo un anno quando mi
hanno chiamato dall'ufficio del
personale per rinnovare il contratto
ho detto che non avrei rinnovato e mi
ricordo ancora la faccia di questa
signora che continua a dirmi mai sicuro
ci vuole pensare per qualche altro
giorno ero sicuro avevo già deciso
quindi da lì è partita una crisi
esistenziale importante perché comunque
sono sempre stato un po irrequieto mi
sono sempre annoiato a fare per molto
tempo la stessa cosa però a un certo
punto che volevo fare io nella vita
volevo andare a new york mi è stata data
la possibilità di farlo è passato il
treno o l'aereo in quel caso avevo detto
di no volevo lavorare in televisione mi
aveva assunto la rai è un certo punto me
ne ero andato che volevo fare tutte le
scelte sono state dettate dal cuore nel
senso che in quel momento da dentro
sentivo qualcosa che mi diceva non è il
momento giusto lascia perdere però sto
cuore lo sapeva che dovevo pagare pure
l'affitto le bollette
c'era una fantastica barzelletta che mi
ha raccontato una professoressa della
george mason university so se la
conoscete c'è quel uomo che prega dio
chiedendogli di di vincere la lotteria
ti prego dio io sono una persona buona
con questi soldi potrei aiutare un sacco
di gente me lo merito sempre vissuto per
bene la prima la seconda la terza la
quarta volta a un certo punto dio
peccato sia facile dicevate lo vuoi
comprare il biglietto e quindi io mi
sentivo un po in questa condizione nel
senso che avevo ricevuto in mano due
biglietti vincenti per la lotteria
entrambi i casi gli avevo buttati via
sì è una lotta continua tra il cuore e
la ragione la ragione e mi diceva che
non deficiente fondamentalmente e non me
lo diceva solo l'area della ragione me
lo diceva anche il mio capo l'ex capo
redattore del tg3 che adesso tra l'altro
è direttore di un'importante testata
giornalistica rai che che era
assolutamente spaventato cercava di
convincere me mi diceva non fareste la
cretinata e me lo dicevano anche la mia
famiglia me lo dicevano i miei amici
però io non è che quelle cose non le
volessi fare ma volevo farle in modo che
andasse che fosse congeniale a me e
quindi nonostante avessi questa questo
dramma interno
comunque mi sono sempre impegnato per
far sì che i treni potessero di un nuovo
ripassare per creare le condizioni
perché queste situazioni si potessero
verificare in futuro nuovamente e per
farvela breve visto che c'è un timer che
che scade
praticamente è successo qualche tempo
dopo qualche anno dopo che mi sono
trovato a firmare un contratto da
supervising producer per con la gestione
del personale della produzione della
serie di corrispondenza rai più
importante al mondo
sapete dove a new york
esattamente quindi due pool 2 piccioni
con una fava si suol dire e in quattro
anni che ho ricoperto questo ruolo
davanti al madison square garden ci sono
passato un sacco di volte non dico che
praticamente ci passavo quotidianamente
ma quasi
e ogni volta che guardavo quella
quell'insegna quella scritta mi veniva
da ridere e soprattutto l'anno scorso è
successo che per caso in un ristorante a
roma ho rincontrato l'ex caporedattore
quello che si era in panne icato perché
io ho lasciato il lavoro
ed è successo all'indomani della
pubblicazione sulla stampa della lista
dei candidati per il consiglio di
amministrazione della rai in cui
qualcuno incredibilmente aveva inserito
anche me
ora non sono mai diventato un
consigliere d'amministrazione della rai
perché non avevo i numeri per farlo però
sono stato molto contento quando il mio
ex caporedattore mi ha detto alla fine
avevi ragione tu
il treno era ri passato sono stato
fortunato certo però ci sono molte
persone che hanno iniziato con me il
percorso della vita che purtroppo non ci
sono più e quindi io credo che noi
abbiamo la necessità
dobbiamo in qualche modo provare a
superare tutti gli ostacoli che la vita
ci mette davanti anche per loro perché
loro non possono più farlo e quindi
questa cosa mi continua ad animare
quotidianamente per fare il mio lavoro e
formi degli obiettivi sempre più lontani
oggi al di là della produzione
televisiva e delle news
ho realizzato 20 documentari di cui 11
come autore regista e 9 come produttore
esecutivo
la maggior parte dei documentari che ho
realizzato sono stati prodotti sempre
dalla rai
la maggior parte di loro in particolare
la rai cinema in collaborazione con una
società che è quella società americana
che fa capo a quella persona che ho
conosciuto sulla spiaggia di soverato a
cui sono sempre rimasto legato nel corso
della vita e con cui ancora oggi
collaboro ho avuto la fortuna di
viaggiare tantissimo ho visto posti
meravigliosi dai camini delle fate in
cappadocia fino a al fiume san lorenzo
in canada
ho incontrato persone meravigliose che
quotidianamente si danno da fare e
lottano per far sì che nel momento in
cui hanno perso un treno questo treno
possa ripassare che lottano per superare
tutti gli ostacoli della vita è che sono
per me di continua ispirazione di
quotidiana ispirazione
ho incontrato per esempio omar omar e
una playlist di 43 anni che detiene tre
record italiani è un record mondiale con
meno 131 metri di profondità
omar fumava due pacchetti di sigarette
al giorno fino a 25 anni
a un certo punto ha deciso che doveva
smettere di fumare non solo ha smesso di
fumare è mai diventato campione del
mondo in una disciplina in cui la
gestione del dei polmoni del diaframma e
del di tutto ciò che avviene all'interno
del nostro corpo diventa fondamentale
per raggiungere determinate determinati
livelli
ho incontrato kidanè kidanè è un ragazzo
africano
un ragazzo di origine africana e malato
in italia che parla quattro lingue ha
una laurea
parla quattro lingue più diversi
dialetti magrebini e che potrebbe fare
qualsiasi cosa nella vita perché gli
arrivano continuamente offerte di lavoro
ma lui ha deciso che deve stare in mare
a dare una mano ai migranti che arrivano
perché è l'unico modo per comunicare
visto che le operazioni di salvataggio
spesso sono pericolose questi non sanno
che cosa devono fare lui ha deciso di
stare là nel mediterraneo ho incontrato
gianni gianni un ingegnere di reggio
calabria che con il suo lavoro onesto ha
costruito un patrimonio immenso che dava
da lavorare a migliaia di persone non
solo in calabria ma anche fuori e che ha
portato la squadra di pallacanestro di
reggio calabria ai massimi livelli nel
campionato italiano
gianni è rimasto invischiato in una
vicenda più grande di lui più grande di
me più grande di tutti noi messi insieme
accuse molto pesanti da cui poi però lui
si è sempre difeso e con l'aggiunta di
un ragazzino oggi che ha 85 anni è
uscito fuori a testa alta da 18 anni di
processi che hanno fiaccato nell'anima e
nel corpo e ancora oggi è riuscito a
fare lui causa per richiedere indietro i
danni di tutto ciò che aveva che gli era
stato tolto
ho incontrato roberta roberta è una
giovanissima professoressa di
neuroscienze la cornell university di
new york poco prima di
di partire per gli stati uniti per
coronare il suo sogno sua madre si è
ammalata ed è venuto a mancare nel giro
di pochi mesi e roberta ha capito che
per superare questo trauma l'unica cosa
che poteva fare era dedicarsi a curare
gli altri e quindi oggi a capo di un
team di ricercatori che praticamente
cura quotidiane cerca quotidianamente
una cura contro il parkinson
ho conosciuto mariangela ho conosciuto
mariangela che il cui figlio è morto
prematuramente in un incidente
motociclistico sulla statale 106 e
marianna è diventata lei stessa una
motociclista col suo marito va in giro
per i motoraduni perché vuole conoscere
le persone che hanno con che hanno
voluto bene a suo figlio per mantenere
vivo il ricordo ho incontrato camilla
una ragazza di 26 anni che coronaro
laurea in tasca da firenza è partita per
gli stati uniti per realizzare il suo
sogno di lavorare all'onu e trovare uno
strumento musicale realizzato da suo
nonno che lei non ha mai conosciuto
quando era lì per mantenersi ha lavorato
all'interno di un ristorante ea un certo
punto è arrivata una proposta lavorativa
incredibile che lei ha rifiutato perché
ha detto che in cuor suo in quel momento
non pensava di dover accettare quella
proposta è praticamente ha continuato
per la sua strada per inseguire il suo
sogno
sono tutte storie meravigliose che ci
insegnano comunque che nella vita
lottare e andare avanti per raggiungere
i propri obiettivi è fondamentale
molte volte per natura siamo propensi a
prendere la strada più breve quella più
più veloce più immediata che magari può
essere quella giusta o magari no
e come si fa a saperlo io non sono
nessuno per dirvi come si fa a scegliere
la strada però posso dire come l'ho
scelta io io lavoro sempre col cuore
finora è andata sempre bene
grazie
[Applauso]